[Music]
it's the line that turned director M
night Shyamalan into the king of plot
twists turns and shockers I do enjoy
surprising people so it's a very natural
thing right now maybe one day I'll be
suffocated by it but I mean I like I
have a couple ideas in my head and I'm
like ooh I can't wait to to show that
now he's back directing split starring
James McAvoy a kidnapper with over 20
personalities
pardon me sir I think you have the wrong
car and action
he's meticulous is completely forensic
and how he approaches the work and he's
got such an incredibly well realized
vision in his mind of what his film
should be from script to every single
shot in his head
I'd love the klephts moment which is
like so chilling when we did in
rehearsals and you change that one time
I was a chilled but in his decades of
surprising reveals hood M night pick a
favorite I don't know this is a twist
it's the reveal and ensigns with the
water no swing way I find it so
spiritual that moment of that there is
everything makes sense a guy who lost
faith and then he kind of remembers what
his wife said and then he looks around
the room and he sees that his wife was
talking about this moment is I don't
know it always gives me chills when I
see it and I remember when I first saw
it with an audience and then they were
like they were like gasps really in the
room it was kind of sweet and as someone
who's been terrifying us for years
this fact might surprise you there's
nothing to scare you anymore no I'm you
you know me dude I'm I'm totally I'm
fearful I'm not just a fearful dude
I mean I'm almost Kraven I'm like I'm
like I'm coward I'm a coward
I'm a coward Randy so it's like I'm
scared of flying I'm scared of this I'm
scared of like that noise I'm scared of
meeting people I'm scared of going in
the cashier and asking for another this
or that or you know if they get the
order wrong I'm nervous to tell the
waiter you know
I don't know I'm just a blubbering
fearful person
[Music]
you